[Musique]
elle était déjà écrite leur partition
mais ces sommes ne l'ont pas joué comme
il était prévu il aurait dû être
descendant d'esclave mais l'histoire a
fait un joli pied de nez cette fois-là
leurs ancêtres des noirs ou volés à
l'afrique ont échappé au destin qui leur
était réservée
[Musique]
ils se sont retrouvés en terre indienne
dans le nouveau monde aux amériques
libre
ils se sont réfugiés dans un endroit à
peine accessible encore aujourd'hui
[Musique]
depuis il champion russe leur résistance
leur victoire
[Musique]
il m'a dit ok je t'emmène suis moi chez
les miens là où tu ne pourras pas aller
seul livingstone cet endroit du
guatemala où tu te perdra corps et âme
sans moi à une condition respecte le
respect en langage rastocle le respect
ça signifie pas touche à mes dreadlocks
les cheveux
cette base essentielle de la
communication poser mon aventure pouvait
commencer
[Musique]
cool mon gourou qui rentrent les poches
bien remplies quelques dizaines de
milliers de dollars tout de même gagné
durement n'est pas vraiment à la sueur
de son front ils viennent passer trois
mois dans un frigo en alaska
[Musique]
bob marley avec sade en or et son oeil
de verre voguant dans un congélateur sur
les océans du grand nord ça avait l'air
d'être un sacré personnage beaucoup
je suis le gars qui congèle
reste dans les chambres froides du
bateau 100 heures par jour
en général je pars sur les campagnes de
65 jours
c'était quatre ans que je fais ce
travail en amont
bateau c'est un bateau gigantesque re 70
m on s'occupe de toute la chaîne de
préparation du poisson qu'on attrape
et pourquoi tu as choisi de faire ce
travail en alaska
pourquoi je fais ce boulot
parce que ça me permet d'être chez moi
aussi souvent que je le long
de rester aussi longtemps au guatemala
avec ma communauté
il existait donc un endroit sur terre si
extraordinaire qu'il méritait de
travailler comme un forçat quelques
semaines par an j'en rêvais déjà de
celui au pot mais cet horizon lointain
une nouvelle frontière qui sait
alors je me la suis avaler cette journée
de bus depuis la capitale
ça en valait forcément la peine et puis
au terminus je le savais un bateau
m'attendais déjà pour livingstone
j'avais choisi d'affronter la mer avec
cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais pour arriver à destination
certains avaient préféré prendre l'autre
voie possible
une route pour lévis mme stone encore
plus aventureuse
par la jungle
et tous ces dangers
l'air brûlant la moiteur des êtres et
des sons étranges
même pas peur des moustiques nicolas
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un moment de sérénité on
est loin des hommes on a tous ces
animaux cette espèce de musique
mais presque dans un philharmonique
naturel ça c'est sa j'adore
[Musique]
le rio dulce c'est vraiment un endroit
bien particulier
puisque
on s'enfonce vraiment dans la jungle on
a ces espèces de falaise c'est un petit
peu un jardin d'éden donc est ce qui est
amusant c'est que on peut y revenir dix
fois vingt fois ça vous fera toujours la
même chose on fait vraiment cette
impression d'être loin de tout
[Musique]
nicolas un de ces touristes baroudeur
attirés par l'exotisme le dépaysement ce
serait ne rien comprendre un jour il est
tombé amoureux de ce paradis perdu et de
ses habitants livingstone là bas tout au
bout du fleuve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fin de mon périple avec où coule par
l'autre voie la mer des caraïbes
c'en était presque fini plus qu'une
heure de bateau livingstone me voilà qui
arrivait à toute bringue c'était sans
compter les caprices des embarcations
cool il m'a fait le fameux coup de la
panne sans avait de l'alluré en pleine
mer dans un bateau taxi brousse dans le
taux ni comment ça va
tellement jour de ton grand frère et un
coq au mans tu vas
alors plus d'essence
le temps du ravitaillement j'ai tout
appris le coup de foudre de tiki tiki le
coup de sang de juanito ndi qui s'était
fait la malle les problèmes de six
leviers avec son bébé les soucis de
coeur au fait vous connaissez la
dernière carlos il s'est expliqué sa
femme par un autre gars il est super
énervés
moi
j'ai débarqué avec où coule à la nuit
tombée je les ai vus tout de suite steve
king
l'homme qui revient du froid
le roi de la ville c'est qu'il en a de
l'ambition au cou cool il veut devenir
maire de livingston il m'a confié
mer rien que ça là je le voyais d'emblée
en campagne électorale
ça va
penser il avait émigré aux états unis à
l'adolescence et puis il a choisi de
revenir vivre à livingstone pour
défendre sa communauté de quoi tirer le
respect des siens les sous qu'il gagne
en alaska c'est pour ces deux enfants
restés aux etats-unis le reste suffit
pour vivre ici une chambre dans un vieil
hôtel abandonné ouais je vais bien finir
par m'acheter une maison ici un jour
mais bon comme la famille possède cet
hôtel je suis pas si pressé
[Musique]
il m'a dit tu vas voir tu vas te
réveiller au bout du monde
livingstone
très vite j'ai compris ils avaient
raison coule sur ce petit bout de porc
de rien du tout j'ai d'emblée rencontré
une chaîne d'humanité
[Musique]
un sentiment de tour de babel les
paupières à peine ouverte
[Musique]
le travail main dans la main quelles que
soient les origines
allez voir le gars là bas il est chinois
on s'entend bien sans communauté
complète à tous les noirs les latinos
les indiens tous quoi
[Musique]
grand père vient de pologne est tombé
raide allemagne
germain partie de ma famille du pays le
pays d'à côté
aussi le côté de ma mère il ya des gens
du show
[Musique]
biz stone des peaux mates ou ébène
dévisager paix ou des traits fins des
yeux clairs noir [__] des rastas comme
coup cool qui parlent une drôle de
langue
[Musique]
les indiens mayas je comprenais ils
étaient les premiers habitants et
latinos aussi avec l'invasion des
européens les métis passe encore mais
tout s'est dégradé de noir ce faussaire
d'afrique
j'étais un peu perdu
les garifuna qu'il s'appelait
[Musique]
je suis très fier d'être garifuna
les garifuna n'ont jamais été esclaves
notre nation a été fondée sur l'île
saint vincent
des bateaux venus d'afrique
chargés de marchandises humaine en
partance pour le nouveau monde ont fait
naufrage dans les caraïbes
les africains se réfugie libre sur cette
île pas encore colonisés de leur
rencontre avec les indiens mais une
culture et une langue désormais ils sont
carrie funa français anglais tombe bien
les récupérer mais ils se défendent ils
composent même des rythme pour marquer
leur succès comme le solaire
comment il fêtait sa la nuit de la
victoire son livre les femmes ont
inventé un son unique
assez elles jouent avec leurs mains
toutes les femmes ce sont avec leur peau
c'est devenu notre rythme de base
[Musique]
comme ça avec leurs mains
la musique garifuna aînés de ces combats
victorieux
certaines danses aussi ses masques il
imite la gueule que les français les
anglais en fait quand ils se sont
heurtés aux combattants paris qu'il
devait pas être fier être capable de
réduire des millions d'hommes en
esclavage et perdre la face devant une
poignée d'entre eux
les garifunas eux payent encore leur
tête aujourd'hui
fin xviiie ils finissent par fuir deux
mille d'entre eux atteignent par barque
le continent les groupes se disperse au
coin témala il fonde livingstone
[Musique]
toujours ces mêmes rythmes aujourd'hui
depuis 200 ans chaque année ils rejouent
revivent l'arrivée de leurs ancêtres
garifuna les seuls noirs débarqué sans
chaînes aux pieds dans les amériques
ce sont nos ancêtres nos parents qui
nous ont appris peu à peu ce que voulait
dire être garifuna
[Musique]
cette chanson s'appelle lui rohmer
elle raconte l'entrée de nos ancêtres
allaient linkstone quand ils sont
arrivés ici
et c'est pour ça que nous la chante on
toujours aujourd'hui
il la célèbre toujours les garifunas
cette histoire unique ils se retrouvent
tous à livingstone une fois par an le
ballet de bateaux comment c'est déjà ça
arrivait de partout des petite ville d'à
côté bien sûr mais aussi des autres pays
du belize du honduras de plus loin
encore
oui oui j'habite aux états unis
je reviens spécialement pour ce dimanche
5 b je suis ici avec mon frère ma soeur
mais toute la famille et puis mes amis
faut absolument que tu restes pour cette
grande fête c'est dans deux jours cette
invitation de coûts cool je l'ait pas
refuser plus que 48 heures donc avant
les pilotes le point d'orgue une
explosion me l'avait promis les tambours
arriver la ville entière s'apprêtait se
prépare et
assister à la grande célébration des
garifuna une chance un honneur m'a
expliqué nicolas lui avait mis du temps
à être acceptés
comme ils s'étaient entichés des gares
et fiona il s'est accroché il a passé un
an ici il en a même fait un roman c'est
des gens très avertis qu'ils ont quand
même derrière au directeur de l'ugtt moi
je sais quand je suis venu ici vivre
j'avais beau leur expliquer comment
aussi j'avais des origines antillaises
ça suffisait pas ils avaient besoin de
savoir ce que je veux avec qui j'ai fait
et quel était mon discours mais qu'est
ce que j'avais apportées aussi parce que
pour être acceptée intégrer on va dire
dans cet univers il faut aussi montrer
patte blanche
grâce à nicolas juste avant la fête j'ai
pu rencontrer sofia elle cachait bien
son jeu sofia pour les visiteurs de
passage elle affiche et son air sérieux
de te nancière de restaurants c'est
qu'elle cuisine et les meilleures frites
à la banane de la ville
et comme j'étais bien accompagné j'ai pu
passer dans l'arrière-cour
et là j'ai découvert sofia en train de
diriger les petits rats de l'opéra
livingstone
[Musique]
l'afer est très sérieuse notre et la
peste il s'envole vers les états unis
ils vont se produire à disneyland pour
faire connaître la culture garifuna
une consécration
[Musique]
intense
moi je prends soin de notre culture je
la nourrit je l'a fait grandir
cette nos ancêtres nous ont transmis
lycée ça que j'enseigne aux enfants
moi je suis une garifuna du guatemala et
j'en suis fier
je suis plus précieux qu'une pièce de
[Musique]
leur culture leur musique avant
d'assister à la grande fête jeu devant
comprendre tout le sens c'est juan
carlos qui m'a guidé un célèbre musicien
garifuna plusieurs tournées en europe et
aux états unis à son actif tout de même
je m'attendais pas à trouver une vedette
internationale ici je les suis vite dans
ces quelques mètres carrés de boue
séchée de paille
maisons traditionnelles garifunas
j'avais construite c'est pour préserver
notre culture
[Musique]
juancarlos
auteur compositeur interprète et grands
prêtres de la culture garifuna
bienvenue chez moi
si les rythmes de base de la musique
n'ont pas changé le sens lui a évolué
les paroles sont moins belliqueuse les
chansons aujourd'hui parlent de la vie
quotidienne des croyances
[Musique]
nous croyons dans la résurrection des
morts
nous pensons que nos grands parents
reviennent d'une vie plus profonde pour
nous aider ici
[Musique]
moreau le spirituel dans notre
communauté c'est celui de messages et de
nos ancêtres
ça m'émeut de parler de la musique
garifuna
elle perdure dans le temps grâce à la
spiritualité
grâce au contrat
nous parle dans les rêves il donne des
idées à la communauté comment faire de
la musique
comment créer des paroles pour une
chanson des rythmes ou encore comment
bouger pendant qu'on joue
[Musique]
honoré les plus vieux les générations
passées coucou ne l'oublient jamais à
chaque retour des états unis il va payer
sa bouteille aux anciens il tenait à me
présenter son grand père une figure un
modèle qu'il disait et des revenus
comment ça va là mon oncle
et ma main qu'est ce que tu as devant
rentrer donc avec ce mauvais temps
non non je reste pas je veux offrir
cette bouteille à mon grand-père assez
bien après je reviens
moi c'était la première fois que je
trinque et à l'éternité
je reviens en bonne santé c'est vrai
mais je te remercie
je te remercie
je t'ai ramener ça pour qu'on boive
ensemble
je voulais partager cette boisson avec
toi
s'il te plaît donne moi la santé
santé le pouvoir afin que je puisse
rentrer
d'abord dieu
et puis toi tu réduis et ben ainsi soit
il
vous devez comprendre que le garifuna la
morale c'est juste un autre stade de la
vienne ce n'est pas la vie qui s'arrête
alors nos ancêtres ont des
responsabilités envers nous mais en
retour nous leur sommes redevables
c'est pour cela que je suis très heureux
que les consignes engorgés et était
réservée à l'ancêtre
mon grand père est en train de sourire
oui
[Musique]
les esprits des défunts qui hante la
ville
le culte de la liberté de l'insoumission
sûr qu'ils entretiennent bien cette
image à livingstone
[Musique]
rien de tel pour attirer les touristes
ça en jette forcément dans une
conversation de raconter qu'on a risqué
sa vie dans une mer déchaînée pour
atteindre cet eldorado
alors évidemment quand vrai routarde
j'allais en ramener des bouts de chiffon
et des tambours de pacotille fait main
j'ai aussi goûter aux spécialités
locales des substances prisé dans le
coin
en quelques heures je ne savais plus qui
était réelle ou pas
mais j'ai vu la vie en rose
j'étais prête pour la vie nocturne de
wellington
tous les week-ends c'était fiesta sur la
plage
sea sex and sun et drogue aussi beaucoup
on en a eues centrale et d'amérique
centrale c'est vraiment de passage
obligé de la drogue entre la colombie et
les états unis viennent au mexique
ok bon balle forcément ça passe un
moment donné par ici
[Musique]
la fièvre du samedi soir version
garifuna uniquement
[Musique]
les autres communautés de livingston
pendant ce temps là c'était plutôt
boulot dodo boulot
[Musique]
aussi les indiens mayas ils ont passé
une nuit blanche
ils se sont pas trop amusé
il
je
13h dans l'obscurité harponné la
crevette
retour aux aurores de la flotte de
livingston
80 navires et pains garifuna sur le pont
pour tancer garifuna ils sont arrivés
par bateau sur le continent avant il
était un navigateur pêcheurs
aujourd'hui seule une poignée d'entre
eux travaillent encore sur des barques
c'est à cause de ces serial killer de
crevettes qu'ils disent ils auraient
vidé l'abbaye n'y aurait plus de
poissons
les pêcheurs maya et latino n'ont pas la
même interprétation
là c'est plus ou moins comme d'habitude
c'est peu très peu
et on n'a pas le choix on doit continuer
un travail crevant pour trois fois rien
5 euros par jour les garifunas eux on
trouve un autre filon
je suis né ici j'ai connu celui quand il
n'y avait presque pas de maison
il y avait quelques baraques construites
sur pilotis
la plupart déjà au site et des garifunas
saison commence à émigrer aux états unis
beaucoup de familles auraient fini son
parti
et ceux qui restent ici reçoivent de
l'enjeu n'est mort mais bon ce sont en
tout on est tous égaux n'y a pas de race
on est tous pareil
sauf le noir
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle beaucoup de
garifuna ont émigré aux états unis
c'est pour chercher des lendemains
meilleurs
c'est pas pour s'offrir une bmw
c'est pas pour parier wall street lui
là bas tu peux gagner assez young est
resté un enough pas besoin de devenir
riche beau
et puis tu reviens
[Musique]
aux
états unis ce n'est pas notre terre
chez eux c'est ici livingstone guatemala
la voilà donc cette fête internationale
qui déplace des flots de garifuna dans
leurs mains des branches d'arbres des
feuilles des fruits
évocation symbolique des trésors que
leurs ancêtres avaient emporté avec lors
de leur fuite par la mer
[Musique]
la célébration de leurs noces avec la
liberté
[Musique]
toute une journée toute une nuit je me
suis perdue avec où coulent nicolas et
les autres au son des chants et des
tambours
un petit coup de bouteille et cool qui
s'est encore mis à refaire le monde
[Musique]
quand je reviens je vois comment ça se
passe à l'étranger
à l'extérieur du guatemala les linkstone
c'est la joie et que je comprends ce que
veulent dire les mots garifuna
à monein
à abou hamous nos toits pour moi moi
pour toi la solidarité quoi ça y est je
commençais à le comprendre un peu le
garifuna
je crois que ça a plu aux ancêtres ont
fait un petit clin d'oeil
[Musique]